hi i'm sal khan founder of the khan
academy and i just want to let you know
about our india talent search as you
might know khan academy we're a
not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and to us that means
that if you are a villager someplace and
you don't have access to a formal school
then you might be able to access a
low-cost smartphone and then be able to
self-educate yourself and one day prove
what you know so you could get a job or
go into higher education but ideally
you're using khan academy in conjunction
with the classroom where the classroom
can allow students to learn and work at
their own pace give data to teachers
free up class time for more open-ended
projects or peer-to-peer learning or
socratic dialogue and so we have a call
out for the talent the teaching talent
in india
to work with us by being part of this
talent search one you'll get a chance to
practice making videos yourself and
we're looking for folks in math and
science and
initially but eventually all subjects
but it's really it's a way for us to
find talent talent that can help us
create content that will educate tens of
millions of learners throughout india so
the opportunity here is i think pretty
exciting there will be prizes but maybe
the biggest prize of all is the
opportunity to contribute and to help
your fellow citizens and now i'm going
to hand it off to anand who is our head
of content in india
i'm really really excited to invite you
to khan academy india's second talent
search
we've been looking for teachers to help
us reach our mission uh of creating
content that's relevant to the indian
learners now one big piece of this is to
map our content to the indian syllabus
which means the content that you create
will be used directly by teachers and
students millions of them
to help their school experience directly
now another big piece of what we want to
do for india is to make khan academy's
content available
in all major indian languages now we
already have khan academy available in a
few indian languages but we really want
to take it to the next step over here
now to achieve both of these in my
opinion the most important thing is to
find the right content creators
not just creators who are passionate
about their subjects but also creators
who are really passionate about making
education available
to millions of learners and that's the
primary purpose of this talent search
we'll be looking for science and math
teachers and content creators in five
languages english and hindi but also
kannada tamil and marathi
and we're looking to give out ten
winners or give out prizes for ten
winners one winner and one runners-up in
each of these five languages so if you
are a creator or if you know a creator
make sure you spread the word and help
as many people know about this talent
search and help us find the right
content creators to get closer to our
mission the last date for sending your
entries is december 17th and now i'm
happy to introduce two of last year's
winners who now work with us mahesh and
ram to say a little bit about their
experience with khan academy hi my name
is mahesh shanay i was the winner of the
last year's india talent search and now
the newest and a proud member of khan
academy team india over the past two and
a half years i've been making youtube
physics videos and so i've learnt a
great deal about video creation however
two days with this team and i realize i
have so much more to learn we are a
small team of passionate people but with
a huge mission a mission to educate tens
of millions of young lives of india and
if you feel you too have the same
passion and here's an opportunity to
join us hi i'm ram one of last year's
talent search winners i love physics and
i've been teaching it for a long time
what i'm excited about is that now i can
help millions of kids in the country
love physics the way i do and since the
entire content is free that means even
the kids who do not have a short quality
education can now educate themselves
using my videos so if you want to help
us in achieving our mission please do
send us your videos and trust me video
creation process is a lot simpler and
more fun than it seems like now when we
evaluate your videos we will look a lot
more at your content depth and
explanation rather than fancy visuals or
production value so make sure that or
rather don't hesitate to just point your
camera at a piece of paper or a board as
you explain your idea now remember that
the last date is december 17th and make
sure you spread the word